dice encuentra el valor absoluto de x
cuando x es igual a 5 x es igual a menos
10 y x es igual a menos 12 ahora bien el
valor absoluto la manera de escribirlo
es todavía más complicado que lo que en
realidad es entonces simplemente esto se
refiere el valor absoluto se refiere a
la distancia de x al 0 eso es todo es es
sencillamente eso la distancia desde el
0 al número x aquí tengo la recta
numérica y aquí está el 0 entonces ok
pensemos en el valor absoluto de x
cuando x es igual a 5 ajá simplemente
voy a sustituir 5 por el x entonces cuál
es la distancia del 5 al 0 veamos es 1 2
3 4 5 de 9 5 unidades desde el 0 al 5
por lo tanto el valor absoluto de 5 es
igual a 5 y como puedes ver es un es un
concepto bastante fácil bastante
sencillo
ahora vamos con uno más interesante el
valor absoluto de x cuando x es igual a
menos 10 entonces cual la distancia del
-10 al 0 tenemos menos 1 - 2 - 3 - 4 - 5
menos seis menos siete menos ocho menos
nueve menos diez alargó la recta
numérica esto es menos 10 qué distancia
hay del -10 al 0 son 10 unidades hacia
la izquierda del 0 entonces ponemos aquí
un 10 y en general el valor absoluto
será una cantidad positiva estamos
pensando en distancia es una distancia
jamás será negativa a todas las
distancias son positivas
el valor absoluto de un número será la
versión positiva de ese número ahora
hagamos por ejemplo este el valor
absoluto de menos 12 aquí es más ni
siquiera hay por qué ver la recta
numérica simplemente será el 12 positivo
ajá o bueno veamos la recta numérica si
acá agregó dos unidades más porque
estamos en menos 10 menos 10 menos 11
menos 12 nos movemos 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 y
10 unidades hacia el cero